哈喽今天是说毛孔的一起干货分享
可以就是
素眼来拍这一期
我是13年的有动几
之前我分享我的剧斗经验的时候
就有节目来跟我留言说
很羡慕我
因为我好像直上斗斗
但是脸上的毛孔是很细膩的
很其实不是的
我的斗斗好了之后
毛孔就在脸上非常的明显
你一脸测这边就有很多那种
秘密麻烦的小黑斗
刀头也是之前是有长几千
它的斗斗都没到之后
我头上还是留了很多的小洞
但是经过我这几年的努力
不是说脸上完全没有毛孔了
社交距离下开了我的皮膚还挺心腻的
这条我会从梭毛孔的原理
以及对应的方法来分享我
距离是怎么操作的
完全没有广告
首先我觉得梭毛孔
他是有一定的先后设设的
第一步一定是定期的做好毛孔的梭通
我们才能防止毛孔持续的变大
因为大部分毛孔出大的姐妹都是有皮
你们很少会看见
赶紧姐妹的毛孔出大
油皮的出油量很大
脚支产油很厚
油脂就都堆机在里面
毛孔就被动的
被你这些油脂沉得越来越大
我们很多油皮的毛孔
就是这样被沉大的
我比一次前面这里就有几个超级大的动
那毛孔说通我做过最有效的方法
就是我制定毕竟分享那个
家庭版毛孔生存清潔
他比我们担用什么清潔面模样
或者什么模杀高啊
都要有效果
每次做完都能把我浅增
和生存的油脂都给我清出来
毛孔会变得超级赶紧
应期把油脂清赶紧
才能防止毛孔被油脂持续的沉大
也可以让后续锁毛孔的沉增
更好的发挥出效果
不然那些沉增多
被这些油脂肚在皮膚外面
你根本吸收不到什么
这也是很多油皮姐妹
绝对护服品没有效果的原因之一
这个生存清潔的方法
我是22年分享在小龙书的
已经四年过去了
还是有很多很多的姐妹
一直在坚持美洲打卡
做好定期清潔之后
就可以开始用一些锁毛孔的沉增了
酸和A唇是我觉得
对有效果也是最有性价比的两个成分
而且他俩对于锁毛孔来说
却一不可的
毛孔他的形状就是这种像圆追形一样
我们看到的皮膚表层
是这个毛孔他最大的一层
然后越往里走毛孔运小
酸是可以加速我们皮膚的代謝的
他就可以把我们毛孔最大的
最外层加速帮我们代謝掉
那我们这个里面的
毛孔嫩嫩的小小的部分
就会录出来
你就会感觉A好像毛孔变小了
酸的话我最喜欢用的
就是这种酸洞模类性的产品
他是一个富好酸
就是里面会有好几种酸
什么说通毛孔的摄影酸
然后帮我们加速代謝的果酸都有
这个是我常用的酸洞模
就是我每次用完台
我的毛孔会呈现一个收紧的一个状态
他更好的点
就是用完之后
你是需要去洗掉的
洗完之后
我后续的恢复就可以加A唇很高效
那A唇
他除了能帮我们表皮加速代謝之外
他还可以刺激我们下面的表远
你的毛孔他本来就是一个洞
你肯定要让他交远
他才能够把这个洞填下来
果外的话是很早很早
就开始用这个成分
他不只做毛孔效果红号
他可以老效果也是非常好的
我之前是分享过好几款
A唇的一唇
你们可以在我的主页
送这条笔记
然后这个毛孔竟话
应该是我前面几条一唇
笔记里面没有分享的
他这个里面就是酸加A一起
很高效
但是他又不会说过于刺激
如果没有那么多的时间
花家呼呼上的话
这个就是很方便
那为了避免广告协议
这个我也不多说了
那就是我发现25架
想酸毛孔的姐妹
除了把酸A用起来之外
卡腰把姜远不起来
我二十多岁的时候
酸毛孔
我是没有注意补姜远这一点的
但是我现在三十一岁的嘛
我发现这点很重要
好像找遍全网
也没有看到什么功课
我是无意中发现的
我一开始补姜远
我除了可以老的
我想二里面的更加风银
但是我发现补一半时间之后
我除了连遍风银了之外
我的毛孔也变小了
跟我一起补姜远的姐妹
他们也是同样的感受
原来我们很多二十五家的油皮姐妹
我们的毛孔都是符合型的
又不有油纸成大的毛孔
又有交缘流失行的毛孔
那你把交缘一補
再加上刷A用算
就可以很快地看到毛孔
变心理了
补姜远我个人最爱的就是这一屏
也是我目前用过补姜远
效果最好的一块
这些全部都是我用完的空琴
它还好的点
就是它是交缘直不行的
缺哪不难
它不是那种说
你需要用进去的时候
你再赚化
带产了交缘
它的这个制定是这种
像水一样的
非常非常好吸收
油皮的话一定会喜欢
我平时用酸或者是用A
甚至是加用点资你
我都会拿它去搭配
让我说毛孔的效率更高
是办公备
然后我就是更心急
于算更足的姐妹
我们就可以上一点
科技很活了
这个加用点资你
我自己是用了很多年
我从他们家的2.0用了他们加3.0
它要说毛孔是真的很牛
它和我们在美容院做点资的区别
就是它的光数会更小一些
所以它没有那么的猛
那我在家里面用它打完
我是没有恢复期的
我第二天就可以正常的化妆出门了
我还喜欢它的一点
就是它没有外面打
那么的透过
就是一种会用个两次这样子
最后最后我在分享一个
作弊神器
就是你现在特别心急
马上交给你的
crash会了
你就很想要你的
这个毛孔马上也行
试试这一支物理方式
它是我用过在甜毛孔方面
最厉害的一个东西
它是这种
物思过一感的这种制定
图云了之后之间
就可以引醒
我脸上70%的毛孔吧
它会有一点点的体量
看起来就像那种
蛮深好皮一样
突然之后脸就会变得
又亮又摆毛孔又吸引
我平时去运动了什么的
我就很想用这一支方式
它承证很好
因为我是豆筋
它这个是豆筋、命批
什么玫瑰指批
运妈妈这支全部都可以用的
超级时候我们有皮
因为它的控油力非常的强
那以上就是我搜盲孔的
全部功课
有一点厂
但真的都是我的
肥腐之眼
希望可以帮助到大家
那还有什么疑问
大家可以再评论去对我留言